[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
pete doherty covers the packers for the
green bay press gazette usa today
network in wisconsin if i told you two
weeks ago
aaron rodgers signed sealed delivered
making 50 million a year
or that devonta adams was going to be a
raider you would have said what
i would have said
no way um
i did i always took it as
i always looked at me like it was going
to be a package deal
and rogers wouldn't come back
unless he had assurances
that adams was going to be back you know
rogers
made the point he didn't want to be part
of a rebuild and adams is
you know obviously his go-to guy
and he wants to win the super bowl and
they're a better team with adams and
without him so
um the surprising thing here is that
rogers
agreed to come back knowing that this
was at least um a possibility that that
the packers would trade the guy which
reportedly he knew it was a possibility
see that's what i found interesting if
i'm aaron rodgers and i know that
devante adams doesn't want to come back
then i would probably lean towards
rogers wanting to leave if adams or talk
adams out of wanting to leave and go
play for for the raiders here like i'm
the the aaron rodgers angle is really
interesting to me pete with the timing
of it and he's going to lose one of the
best if not the best wide receiver in
football
yeah but it surprises me too and you
know i mean the money obviously mattered
because he signed this deal that's
paying him a legit you know 50 mil a
year rogers did that but
if they traded him to denver i'm sure
denver would have or somebody else they
would have paid him the same thing
i think he saw the packers
as the best chance for him to get back
to the super bowl i mean almost all the
you know mostly good quarterbacks are in
the afc now so the path to the super
bowl is a little easier and the nfc
packers have a lot of talent still so
you know they're a good team
um so but adams would have been a big
part of that calculation or at least
i thought it was and
you know we haven't heard from him
and the packers are the ones as far as i
can tell who are leaking the information
that rogers knew that this was a
possibility
so maybe
they're overstating the case and maybe
he's not so happy i will you know we'll
find out
in the coming weeks and months they did
get some assets in return but
you know i don't know if you think dan
but i you know maybe two years from now
this helps them out a lot if they hit on
these draft picks but for 2022
you know their super bowl chances
probably take a dip here i don't see how
they don't without what a great player
adams is and you mentioned pete that
you think the packers leaked this
information just to let their fan base
know we did everything that we could
possibly do
and it felt like they were saying that
about aaron rodgers like hey we want him
uh you know he's going to be the highest
paid quarterback uh they didn't say
anything negative and they're probably
doing the same thing kind of covering
their tracks with devante adams was he
going to make as much if not more if he
stayed in green bay
that's what the leak
again i'm sure from the packers said
is that he was going to make the city
now contract structure you never know
about that stuff guaranteed money and
never know for sure about that but
um they're painting the picture that
they wanted to pay him the same amount
of money and i guess the other kind of
surprising thing about this is i you
know david carr is a pretty good
quarterback if you're ranking all the
quarterbacks in the league he's probably
right about in the middle right
um but
you know adams is moving on from you
know i see why you'd want to play with
him college teammate he probably really
likes the guy but he's leaving you know
one of the best pure passers to ever
you know play the game and i'm sure
adams is thinking hall of fame at this
point of his career
um so i'm a little surprised that you
know he'd be okay leaving
rogers for you know just about any other
quarterback too
if i said you could interview aaron
rodgers today devonte adams today or
brian guticuntz the gm of the packers
today you only got one
just one of them are they on truth serum
i i can't i i i can't have that part of
the uh
the
equation they're not a true serum and
it's on the record then i'd want to talk
to adams
how much do you know about adams did he
ever bring up wanting to play for the
raiders before
you know i saw a quote uh yesterday that
i'd forgotten about he was asked about
it really early in the season last year
and he said you know he he didn't
dismiss the possibility he said hey you
never know what's going to happen i love
david carr it'd be great to play with
him again
that's something to that effect so you
know he did telegraph that this was at
least a possibility in his mind
yeah i just i it feels like aaron
rodgers is going to get blamed for this
should he
for adam's leaving yeah
because he gets blamed for everything
else yes he does yes he does
yes he does um yeah well that's
obviously that's why the packers leaked
what they did
it wasn't our fault
uh
is this is this still a threatening team
like
if you're going to handicap the nfc
right now we don't know what they're
going to do with that those draft picks
but brady back
rams got alan robinson um i don't know
if you the cowboys seem like they might
be stuck in neutral here so
handicap the nfc where do the packers
fit in without devante adams
oh they're still right up there but
they're you know their percent of
chances of winning it you know go down
at least a couple notches you know a
couple percentage points
um the thing that you know jumps out to
me because adam's going he produces
great which is huge but he also changes
the way
that teams defend the packers he
commands double teams and all that
coverage so he makes other guys better
too um i'm sure they're going to have to
sign a veteran or two you know but it's
going to be mid to lower tier guys
they're going to draft
at least two receivers i wouldn't be
wouldn't be a shocker if there were two
in the first three rounds even what do
they have four or five picks there to
work with in the first three rounds five
picks
uh but rick you know we know rookie
receivers often have trouble uh
contributing so
i mean i still think they're right there
they've got bacteria back
and uh alexander back both of those guys
basically missed all last season and
they still had you know the best record
in the nfc so yeah i think they're still
really dangerous good running game they
got here aaron rodgers as their
quarterback they're just a little
less equipped now
when they're playing their their best
teams unless they just hit huge on a
draft pick who's ready to play a lot of
good football you know right out of the
gate your job's too easy pete
imagine imagine if you covered the
jaguars i mean
well last year would have been
interesting but you you got a story the
stories write themselves for you
they do like um last time we were i was
on we were talking about you know the
circus was coming to downtown because
ron rogers was
demanding a trade so look how much
things change
in one year and he's back and now who
knows maybe next year he wants out again
were you there for all of farb's career
i was
how does that compare drama the drama
meter
these packages no i didn't think it i
didn't think it could get higher than
far but it has managed to um with all
the covet stuff last year with rogers
and wanting the trade and now all of
this it's um
it always ends up the same with these
star quarterbacks i guess
pete thanks for joining us have a great
weekend we appreciate your time
sounds good dan appreciate you having me
that's uh pete daugherty he's the packer
columnist for the green bay press
gazette